this is gorgeous thank you how did you
get in the car with it I don't really
know I really don't right over in a car
yes it did
no I heard bicycle no in the car you
could have walked it we walked over from
the hotel nearby good that was a good
idea right yeah very good idea sad how
did you sit the Scot was more like up in
my face but it was fine it's not like it
was I was like in a tent I probably had
to like have three spaces or something
for that dress but it's worth it right
yes are you a New York Fashion Week is
that where you found your dress yeah we
had a fitting there actually yeah so
yeah yeah well we got the sketch about
two months ago and it took two months
nearly two months to make this beautiful
dress and then there yeah no but it's
been yeah definitely a rollercoaster
with finding what I like and more like
how long I want it and how tight you
know it's yeah it's good beautiful
though I love it you know do you ever
think about your life face this way
Olympics I would see a pretty face
oh do you ever think about you're like
14 years old you made times most
influential when you heard that and you
think about your life and everything has
happened you go wait a minute I'm just
14 yeah yeah no but I I don't really
think about it I think it's best not to
think about otherwise it'll freak you
out so I just kind of like oh I'm like
oh I'm at the Emmys I'm really grateful
but I think about it too hard it freaks
you out
so yeah hey do your friends say anything
you hang out with other 14 year old yes
I I have a lot of friends luckily I mean
I only have about it should be honest I
only have about five friends like true
friends I could bet my life on that my
age Drake I love you but ya know my age
bless you but ya know I do and they're
great people and I love them good
friends at Kendall Jenner who she
fangirls she's so sweet I love her yeah
she's great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]